you know what I am gonna do though I'm
with my mom passes away and my dad i'ma
put them let them know although
basically from other fruit trick and
then my great-grandchildren and then
i'ma tell I'm a feeding that fruit and
then as I'm about to die I'm gonna bring
them a little closer I let hey kids what
great-grandpa David you be your
great-great-grandparents dead fruit
buddy ha ha and then die Shh cuz you
were talking about earlier about how you
were loved which was very poor yeah yeah
it's like to the point you were so poor
that I would look at you like damn dude
hey life is rough Chris no like I'm over
here drinking clear water [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] stop I mean for a perspective
just tell the people out there how you
grew up cuz I want people to know that
[ __ ] I grew up pretty pretty poor it was
down in Riverside I didn't have a bed
for many many years a mattress on the
ground and the place that we live which
wasn't really a house whose uh it was a
shock that was kind of thrown together
but yeah I mean I I slept in where we
mice and rats sharing the bed with us
and you know I once caught a mouse in my
hand while while napping because it was
just running along the side of my my arm
thinking I was the wall so snapping on
the ground and then I snatched him up
and he bit me and I lost haha right away
and then you had the Black Plague for a
little bit grew up without health
insurance too and it was scary but I
felt that for most for my parents
cuz when you're a kid you don't really
realize how bad it was but I have this
little blurb on my Instagram about
stepping on a nail but that really
happened I stepped on a nail a rusty
nail and I was 11 and when you get your
first end shot after your birth
attendants shot should last for about
ten years
mhm I was 10 turning 11 my parents
literally had the conversation of do you
think the tetanus shot is still working
I had stepped on the nail it went all
the way in he came out as a rusty nail
and I was sitting there and I'm
literally my mom got my dad's whiskey
out in like dab to my foot with it with
the whiskey to kill the germs and they
were like [ __ ] I mean technically the
tetanus shot last 10 years he's already
turned 10 he's going to 11 I mean it
might still be okay and that's why never
went to the hospital
and they took a took a gamble and it
worked out but I mean that is we report
you know and that's great I could just
like picture you leaving the oven your
mama doesn't hugging
you know via live right maybe maybe he
could live I guess give me the corner
the corner okay we don't go see my
parents to they just hate my mom had
this weird constant she thought their
flu could cure everything but I would
sprained my ankle she goes yeah theraflu
like that has nothing to do with my
sprained ankle what does that have it
it's okay better flu like what the [ __ ]
man I stopped and stopped using that
[ __ ] on everything it's like what's it
was at My Big Fat Greek Wedding when
they put Windex on everything yeah that
was better food for my mom she didn't
understand what their fullest fought
through that experience I realized that
we're all a lot tougher than well yeah I
did then then then people lead us to
them the media leads us to think yeah
that's why I never understood this
closet like all Asian men are weak is
like new have you stepped on a rusted
nail and it debated on whether you
should go to the hospital because you
might have tetanus you don't experience
that kind of refugee [ __ ] like I know
like vitamin C like what does it do it's
like good for your immune system like
cell growth or something oh no I'm all
of those Caffery stunts and SunnyD gun I
love you know some best flavor
what does it go cherry capri-sun yeah
oops cateresa loser
you know what I've been fighting over
you know what I've been finding out is
that I'd be saying some [ __ ] that a lot
of normal people don't say like ponies
every Sun you can fascist on the wrong
syllable I don't know I just know that
caproni it's always a short ass jeans
and there's so many ways to say it Capri
so let's see Capri doesn't sound it's
not menacing enough it's not medicine
are you you want three you want to have
your [ __ ] some gangsters [ __ ] up at
the Capitol say say say Capri in the
same Capri Capri Caffrey and then yes I
want you say both with emphasis Caffrey
that's really hard like this Capri huh
what's this
Geoffrey Capri yeah Bri know that went
like kind of like an axe I don't even
know was that Capri some it's not police
it's police cuz I always assumed there
was police because people called the
Popo didn't call it the papa